this guy is weird i'm just going to
ignore him time is soon
so you know how hard our relationship
has been right
[Music]
hi guys i'm joanna hello what's the
parents so
as you can see today's video is very
casual there is pretty much no structure
to this video
um yeah i i know he doesn't want to do
this video take a video
and
sensitive yeah so basically we have been
together for close to four years now and
this here is rusty rusty is already
eight years old so today's video we'll
be asking each other some questions some
personal questions
some sensitive questions which he's like
you know he doesn't want to answer i
know that
but
let's just have fun okay
[Laughter]
yeah so
i think one of the things that you
notice about our relationship is that um
in a way we're bilingual so my first
language is english whereas teresa's
first language is
yeah so that's the reason why we're
doing this video bilingual as well so i
think it'll be fun for both our audience
to hear us speaking in english and also
mandarin
okay so are you ready okay
holla
[Music]
so this goes four years back right
guys
he was the one that actually
messaged me on instagram to begin with
and this was back in what december 2017
i think at that time yeah you you had a
bicycle accident remember
today so he had a bicycle accident he
was in the hospital i guess he was bored
correct you were bored there was nothing
to do you were recovering for what two
weeks to one month
but but that's the truth and then he
messaged me on instagram and i honestly
i can't remember i think he was
commenting on one of my stories so i was
like oh this guy is weird i'm just going
to ignore him which i did
now
uh
uh
you got absolutely
so yeah i mean yeah that's true so we
got to know each other from a fitness
app that we were involved in so he
messaged me long story short i ignored
it and then i think he commented on
another video a few months later i
ignored it as well and then one day he's
like oh do you want to work out together
i'm like no
because i find it weird you know a
stranger in a way it's someone you know
but you don't know that person asking
you whether you want to work with um
with him and i'm like no
and then
what eventually six months later
only then
we decided to meet up yeah jesus
[Laughter]
but i don't think we're even answering
the question okay the question was what
what what was the question
i mean i think it was in a way our first
proper date because the first time i met
him i actually took another guy friend
out
[Laughter]
yeah so the first time we met each other
i actually took another guy out so i was
i wouldn't consider consider that our
date i think our first proper date was
in starbucks where he
he was prepping for his competition so
he actually cooked you know his meal
prep and then he cooked my meal prepped
he actually made me this
egg salmon wrap remember
look at him
he's shy
so i would say it was his cooking
yeah what about you
good job
i think for me is that we are very
supportive towards each other i think
that's a very important thing in a
relationship is that you know i know he
has his goals and dreams that he wants
to achieve especially in the
bodybuilding industry so i'm very
supportive towards him
and in return he's also very supportive
towards me you know in my in in terms of
you know my work my career
everything that i do including running
my own company as well so i think
that is
that is one of the biggest thing that
i love most about our relationship is
that we're always supportive towards
each other and we're never like you know
um
putting each other down or like
[Music]
i think that's very important because
sometimes no matter how good you are in
your career
but if you don't have a supportive
partner you know that person can always
pull you down
so in in this regard we don't have that
issue we're always you know trying to
lift each other up trying to understand
each other trying to see you know how
can we help each other to be better so
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
i'm upset right now
so for him i think one thing about him
that i really love is that he has a very
big heart so a lot of people see that
he's a big guy but actually they don't
realize that he also has a very big
heart what i mean by that is that
he he really paid attention to all the
small details
he cares about you know whether i've
eaten you know how am i at work you know
if i have a long filming day he would
ask me am i tired he would you know care
about how i'm feeling
on that day itself and it's not just
something that you know you do on
occasionally but it's something that he
does regularly so that's something that
you know i think it's a is a big quality
and not just to me but he would do that
to his family members as well his mother
you know his father and his sister which
i think it's it's it tells me what kind
of person he is if he can treat his
family right then he can treat me right
so i think that's a number one really
important quality and
number two for me is
obviously i believe everyone has goals
and dreams
but with him he has his goals and dreams
and he will you know make sure that he
goes after it no matter how long it
takes him
he's very consistent he will put in the
hard work and he will you know work hard
and achieve it
no matter how long it takes so it's not
a matter of oh you know i'm not good
enough oh
it's not working out oh i'll give up no
it's about consistency it's about
discipline it's about you know trying to
be better and keep doing it until you
know you achieve success and even if you
achieve success you will still you will
still um continue to see how you can
improve on yourself
yeah so
should i answer the third one you wanna
you have a third one now
what a question
what are the three qualities not two
i don't know how to say this but i feel
that i have you know
a a partner with me
you know not a partner that's against me
i think that's a very important quality
we're always there to support each other
so i think that's a very important
quality i know that i have someone with
me on my side all the time always
whether it's um in terms of relationship
whether it's it's in terms of
responsibility whether it's it's in
terms of direction i know that i have a
partner with me
[Music]
two three five six ten things that you
you can't say about me is it qualities
you can only say two
ok
so that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay
okay i have to defend myself
it's because you know when you're
working from home
you work at one spot you drink tea
and then you're like oh okay now it's
like time to change spot i'm sure you're
the same okay change spot to the dining
area so every spot every spot got one
glass then you drink coffee on their
spot
and they're like okay i need to stretch
a little bit i go to another spot
there's a toy doesn't matter
sport do i find jesus
okay my turn one thing i can't stand
about him is that
he always sleeps damn late
okay
one o'clock is okay
you know he will always tell a student
or sleep early you know it's gonna
affect you know your your body is gonna
affect your performance and next thing
he's gonna be like sleeping at one
o'clock or two a.m so i really can't
stand that about him i used to sleep at
i would say 10 to 11 p.m in in the
beginning of our relationship i i did
for him he's like come on let's sleep at
11 pm and then he'll be like you know
forcing himself to like close his eyes
but he'll be looking at his phone and
eventually i sort of like give in a
little bit so now it's like 12 to 1 a.m
okay
period of hours
okay don't tell your student to sleep
early okay
i'm
always when it comes to good things
right i have to answer first bad things
right he has you know lots of bad things
to talk about
one of the few small things is that you
know i like how he's he still kisses me
every morning and every night because if
i go to bed early he'll come in and like
it'll give me like lots of kisses
sometimes disturb my sleep
and in the morning as well so that's
once you know small things that i think
people take for granted but i mean he
did it in the beginning of the
relationship and i did actually say to
him ah this will only last for like few
months you know it won't last for long
but he's still doing it four years later
so yeah so that's something i appreciate
and
with rusty i like how he treats rusty
he's very gentle towards rusty he would
like you know
talk to rusty at night at
night to put him to sleep and he would
talk to rusty in the morning
god knows what he says to him but
yeah but i appreciate that
and another thing is that
i know to some people this my this might
be weird
and i know he doesn't like to do it but
i like it
is that okay so i'm one person who
doesn't like to eat apple because i find
it hard to bite into the heart apple
okay
and what he will do for me is that he
will bite a big chunk out
and then he will pass it to me so that's
something that he does
which i know is funny but yeah okay
okay jesus
foreign
[Music]
foreign
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
that
okay
i think
for me it's something more personal i
think my biggest fear i'm gonna be you
know really honest and he knows about it
as well
is that
yes
i'm gonna cry man don't talk
[Music]
i mean
okay sorry
you know how hard our decision has been
right
by not having the support of
i guess in a way my my mom
sorry
okay so i mean i'm gonna be really
honest okay i mean our relationship
hasn't been easy
it's because
i mean
the thing with us is that
we came from different
different upbringings in the sense that
obviously um
one thing my parents has always taught
me is that you know they have always
taught me to you know chase after your
career chase after your dreams do well
in your studies you know all that kind
of things
and so i guess my my whole life
that's what i have been doing you know
do in the studies you know get this
scholarship
pursue your dreams
you know pursue your career what not
what not
and
that's my upbringing with teresa's
upbringing is different because he came
from in a way a broken family you know
his parents are
divorced he didn't have
the guidance from his
i guess his mom he was brought up by his
his dad he didn't have a mother figure
or he didn't have the proper family
structure of you know telling
you to study hard and all that so he
whereas he's very good in sports
so he he grew up from a family where
there's no you know guidance and he only
did what he knew
so long story short
he is who he is today it's not because
of you know getting good grades good
results good scholarship it's not
because of that he is who he is today
because of you know his
he went through the hard way discover
what he's good at and really had to
fight his way up
so what i'm trying to say is
sometimes our parents can not our
parents more like my parents
can be very judgmental they can be very
judgmental in in the sense that you know
you know my mom can look down on
terrence
in terms of you know his upbringing
and
and basically his upbringing and you
know even where he is right now she
doesn't see you know where he came from
his past and who he is today she just
see how he is you know from a broken
family you know a guy that has no a guy
that has no security in a way
you know what i mean so because of that
it has been very hard on our
relationship to not have
that support
and he he knows you know right from the
beginning and obviously he's hurt
but
in a way he knows that you can't you
know force someone to respect you or you
can't force someone to
like you or you know not be judgmental
towards you you can only earn their
respect through time
so
i mean that's what he has been doing
that's what he's been trying to do
and
and he has never been disrespectful
towards my parents ever it's ridiculous
when you think about it i know a lot of
people won't get it but he's from a
chinese educated family i'm from an
english educator family even little
things like that even different
religious background you know all these
little things
it's a big deal
it's hard when your family is just like
you know you know like showing attitude
or you know not being supportive and
and
in a way
i know what my i know what my mom or my
parents are doing is not right so i
shouldn't
you you can't blindly just listen when
you know that
what you have with each other it's it's
strong yeah
it's true what people think doesn't
matter about what your family thinks
matters to the extent that's the thing
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
need three piles yeah
i mean obviously you always want your
family to you know love your partner for
love your partner
i mean i understand you know if you're
like a drug addict or if you're like you
know alcoholic or gambler i understand
all that but this is not even that this
is literally like you know
judging someone because you know they're
from a broken family judging someone
because their family is not
rich judging someone because that person
is less educated
you know or or different religion or you
know being
unstable because he's an athlete from my
opinion it's silly judgments that
we should never place onto you know a
person or any human being ever
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
basically with terence his family is
very simple uh yeah
everything is simple you know
which is you know an important quality
to have in life
i think with my family on the flip side
i mean my family they are go getters so
if they you know set a goal what they
want in life you know they will always
strive to achieve it so that's one thing
that i've learned from my family which i
also think that is an important quality
you know don't just talk
and not you know take any action so
whatever you want in your life you know
don't just say you want this you want
that you want this but you never take
any action or take any initiative to you
know go for it or fight for it so that's
one thing that you know i learned
and i think another thing that you know
we can learn from both our family as
well as that most of the times um
parents would teach us about you know
education career what not but sometimes
they what they
fail to teach us is how to build you
know how to maintain and build a healthy
and solid relationship as well you know
how to live pretty much i think that's
one thing that
you know i think both our family can
teach us to do better
foreign
[Music]
my first wish
is that i want rusty to live forever but
i know it
no
i mean on a serious note i think
i do want him to live as long as he can
at least 15 years
i guess my second my second wish is i
guess more personal in the sense that
you know i want our family to be fully
integrated
yeah fully accepting of each other and
just really fully integrated and
happy and you know can you know go on
holidays together and whatnot
the final thing is
i want to go and see narwhal
[Laughter]
yeah i mean it's definitely something on
our bucket list it's not cheap it's like
what ten thousand to fifteen thousand
usd per person
so yeah would you mind
um
foreign
okay guys so that is the end of you know
um getting to know us on a deeper level
it's not an easy video to film it's not
easy to you know open up yourself
you know he's like nervous doing this
video as well
because
you know on social media
we always see other people or you know
even when you look at us you think it's
all happy happy it's all fun fun it's
all you know like yay you know we have a
great relationship
but the reality is that you know there
are issues that everybody has to deal
with
and
yeah so
uh relations
here
but saying that i mean i believe that we
will only
go stronger from here on i think that i
mean i i know that time you know will
prove how much we love each other
and that
um
yeah and that everything will
heal and become better i have you know a
lot of love for him
typical asian guy
all right guys so
let us know um what you know if you have
any other questions and we love to hear
your thoughts let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to my youtube channel go on to
his channel and hit the subscribe button
as well
bye
[Laughter]
he's like no no
[Laughter]
he's shy see he's the shy one